demandez vous l'avez patienter vous avez
voici comme le titre l'indiqué la
première partie de ma bibliothèque
première partie parce que déjà je n'ai
pas encore ramené tous mes livres ici
dans ce bureau et première partie parce
qu en une seule vidéo ce ne sera pas
possible
et pour vous parler de mes livres il me
faut aujourd'hui un outil indispensable
mes lunettes on va se poser
tranquillement ici puis je vais prendre
les livres un peu dans leur dos ils
viennent et peut-être aussi par ordre
historique par exemple ça c'est un des
premiers livres que j'ai eu et qui m'a
ouvert à plein de choses ça s'appelle
cours magica de robert v no la version
de ce cocktail assez 1954 et à
l'intérieur de ce bouquin j'ai pu
trouver tout ce qui était manipulation
de pièces de cartes est vraiment écrit à
l'ancienne avec de magnifiques planches
dessinées à la main qui expliquait les
mouvements comment les faire etc
c'était découpé en chapitres en douze
leçons dont ma première rencontre avec
le mentalisme dans ce chapitre là appelé
magnétisme spiritisme divination et
transmission de pensée et la douane
aborder un sujet qui était le patron luc
ya pas de trucs
ce qui me fait immédiatement penser à un
autre livre de doc les principes
brillant du mentalisme qui contenait
justement un chapitre qui s'appelle ya
pas de trucs et la version française de
ce bouquin date de 1980 ces deux livres
ont été écrits imprimés avant que je
naisse oui je suis née après 1980
ça va oui alors ces allusions sur mon
âge c'est le j'ai d'abord je m'aime pas
plus et maintenant plutôt que de vous
donner une chronologie je vous propose
de prendre trois livres au hasard d'un
bibliothèque et je vous en bas premier
livre plus buzzer vous allez kiffer
c'est le guide marabouts des échecs les
plus belles tactique c'est un très bon
livre soit dit en passant je vous
raconte l'histoire rapidement je savais
jouer en terme de règles mais j'avais
une très mauvaise stratégie en fait j'en
avait quasiment pas et à l'âge de 8 ans
je partis en vacances avec ma marraine
j'ai rencontré un mec là bas qui joue
aux échecs avait 25 ans et on joue aux
échecs ensemble et en partant il m'a
offert ce bouquin là pour que je puisse
comprendre les principes stratégiques et
tactiques
pas sûr que ce soit un livre comme ça
que vous attendiez on y retourne je
pioche gold reding rapide efficace de
webster
vous n'allez pas trop kiffé si vous
cherchez du col de reading tels que vous
l'entendez à la sherlock holmes c'est
par livre de colle de reading du tout
c'est un livre sur la chiromancie donc
le palmeraie ding la lecture des lignes
de la main eh ben je ne vais pas refaire
mais je les lui et ça m'a profondément
intéressé parce que tout m'intéresse
d'une manière générale je crois pas dans
les lignes de la main je crois pas
nécessairement à tout ça c'est pas grave
ça empêche pas qu' une vraie culture
derrière tout ça et ça empêche pas de
s'intéresser de cette culture là quand
je vous dis que je les lui tu me suis
intéressé et voilà c'est ça c'est que
vous pouvez voir que oui effectivement
en plus je surligne beau
tous les passages qui m'intéresse je re
note parce que des fois je corrige aussi
des mots c'est rigolo si le faire contre
ça touchant parce que moi je tombe sur
des éléments de vie ce livre là je pense
pas que j'aurais pris le temps de vous
en parler réellement si je n'étais pas
tombé dessus au hasard allez prochain
bouquin à jarret parler je crois un
petit peu dans une vidéo dans une
ancienne vidéo du mental blog du mira on
n'était pas nombreux à cette époque que
sur la chaîne j'ai même pas si on était
dix mille quand j'en avais parlé il est
difficile à trouver aujourd'hui c'est un
des meilleurs livres que j'ai lus sur le
mentalisme ex nihilo de d'angélo
stagnaro le sous titre c'était le guide
du col de reading moderne une analyse du
langage du corps de l'intuition et les
kings de l'interprétation des mouvements
musculaires du charisme de
l'anthropologie culturelle des
statistiques des forces psychologiques
des tours de mentalisme de l'observation
de la causalité et du bon sens et ça
fait partie d'une trilogie qui
s'appelait ouvrage psychologique balle a
pu besoin trop voulu détailler par
rapport à tout ce que j'ai dit qu débute
sur la première page
vous avez à peu près le contenu du livre
alors comme tout ce genre de livre il ya
du bon et du moins bon
en fait l'idée pour reprendre le mot
curieuse c'était un petit peu curieux de
tout ça donc il faut jamais se fermer
complètement ça ne coûte rien de lire et
de garder du recul par rapport à ce
qu'on laisse peu après vous éliminer ce
qui ne tient pas la route pour ça qu'on
vient de vivre la 4 c'est tout il faut
que j'en fasse un petit peu plus quand
même next je vais aller un petit peu
plus dans le fonds tient son psy ah
j'aime bien cela influence et
manipulations de ciel d'initier un
professeur en psychologie sociale et il
ya toutes ces années de travaux et de
recherche qui sont à l'intérieur de ce
livre il est assez bien écrit
vient il pas lourd à lire alors vous
attendez pas à voir des images 1 on est
sûr de la théorie pure et dure
extrêmement intéressant de jouer un lien
dans la description je pense qu'on le
trouve encore facilement plus facilement
quelques niveaux parle même de
références historiques sur les claques
les claques
c'est ce qu' au théâtre sont payés
étaient payés du moins ça n'existe plus
vraiment aujourd'hui pour applaudir fort
pour crier fort il y avait le bis heure
par exemple
c'est quelqu'un qui au théâtre au xxème
siècle criaient bizzbee
dix pour que tout le monde en fait et
envie de voir un dernier numéro et parle
de toutes les influences que ça avait
sur le groupe enfin c'est bourré de
choses comme ça à l'intérieur
bon j'en prends un pas au hasard ce
coup-ci l'art de la guerre de sun tzu
c'est une de mes bbc objets comme ça un
top de livres hockey lch est capable de
me référer très régulièrement et qui
m'apporte beaucoup parce qu'ils ont des
lectures intéressantes situent les
transpose sur d'autres univers allez on
part sur un petit lien dans la
description allez je vous en fais un
tout dernier je suis plus du tout
combien en est celle qu'elle a les
énigmes de sherlock holmes j'ai plein de
bouquins denim
il y en a d'autres d'ailleurs à côtoyer
les énigmes dedans je trouve qu a rien
de mieux qu'un livre d'énigmes pour se
stimuler à voir les choses différemment
si vous aimez bien l'univers de charles
comme celui-ci vous allez kiffer qu'est
ce que vous en pensez
on part sur un petit lien dans la
description et bien sûr en plus celui ci
et là particulier d'avoir un fil rouge
enfin celui ci dans aussi un fil rouge
je crois qu'en fait c'est de plus en
plus courant l'élite énigmes avec un fil
rouge et ben voila voila pour cette
première partie de bibliothèques ça me
paraît pas mal tuner comme vous me
réclamer cette vidéo là depuis longtemps
je me suis aussi faisons un test on fait
déjà sept premières parties relativement
rapide je sais pas combien de temps ça
va faire au final
et s'il ya beaucoup de questions dans
les commentaires par rapport à tous ces
bouquins ou si vous vous demandez si
j'ai lu tel ou tel ou tel livre vous
pouvez aussi me le mettre
ce n'est pas coutume un tout petit
rajout vous souvenez de karine hersant
et victor baranger à qui j'avais fait la
faq l'alpha qu ils font chacun de leur
côté de la french pop et pour la
première fois ils vont être en concert
ensemble la semaine prochaine le 23 mars
à paris sur une péniche théâtre là où
j'avais joué moi l'année dernière est
joué vous le dire parce que d'une pour
ce qu'ils avaient fait pour l'alpha q
c'était énorme et de deux parce que ce
sont des artistes de ouf
si vous avez l'occasion aller les voir
j'ai lu karine hersant à l'instant au
téléphone et le petit bonus et que si à
l'accueil à la billetterie vous dites
que vous venez de la part de la team
menthe à l'eau ou que vous faites partie
de la team menthe à l'eau est bien la
deuxième place vous sera offert donc si
vous êtes plusieurs à vouloir y aller
organisez vous dans les commentaires
voilà c'était juste là dessus je veux
dire c'est énorme
moi je rate aucun de leur concert c'est
un très bon week-end je vous donne
rendez-vous lundi pour une vidéo
participative save the date lundi 17h30
ciao
[Musique]